lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
de très nombreux manifestants ont été
arrêtés avant les manifestations
contrôlé au motif qu'ils avaient un
gilet jaune ou quelque chose dans leur
voiture placé en garde à vue
donc déjà nous sommes là dans le
préventif mais le plus grave a été
qu'ils ont été maintenues en garde à vue
du samedi matin au dimanche soir
la fin des manifestants empêchaient à
manifester oui alors le procureur de la
république à assumer cela d'une certaine
façon il a expliqué que c'était une
manière de les empêcher de retourner
manifester là où des infractions des
violences continuaient d'être commise
moi je pense qu'il s'agit d'une
extension du code de procédure pénale
bien bien bien hasardeuse et je pense
que la pratique s'est arrêtée en fait
avec les manifestations de gilet jaune
je pense que vraiment on ne joue pas
avec la justice pénale et c'est pas
possible d'interpréter de cette façon là
les textes ce qui est préoccupant
surtout c'est que finalement quand nous
les avocats ont dénoncé un excès de
pouvoir du procureur des policiers
qu'est ce qu'on fait on demande au
tribunal de le juger et le tribunal ou
donne raison ou nous donne tort on va en
appel en cassation c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne
là rien pourquoi parce que les
manifestants ont été relâchés ils n'ont
pas eu procès rien du tout et donc c'est
très difficile ensuite de leur expliquer
vous savez on va faire un procès contre
l'état et ça va durer 3 ans etc
les gens ils renoncent si vous voulez
donc cette pratique de garde à vue
préventive finalement n'a pas été jugée
excessive alors qu'à mon sens elle l'est
[Musique]